[Musica]
io sono sindaco questo piccolo comune in
provincia di Isernia il confine con
l'Abruzzo è uno dei piccoli comuni come
tanti piccoli comuni che soffrono di un
problema atavico c'è lo spopolamento uso
terremoto silenzioso che sta
depauperando non soltanto l'entroterra
molisano abruzzese Ma tutta la dorsale
appenninica italiana anche un pezzo di
Arpi e che questo territorio rappresenta
il 60% del territorio nazionale
60%, ci vivono 10 milioni di abitanti
questo questo territorio soffre come
dicevo dello spopolamento allora nel
nostro piccolo comune come tanti altri
piccoli comuni non siamo soli da anni
portano avanti una strategia
dell'esistenza ma non passiva a
lamentarci ad attardarci a piangerci
addosso ma Attiva positivo quello
dovrebbe essere tutti quanti portando
avanti una serie di iniziative che hanno
quella l'obiettivo di invertire la rotta
e lo si fa attraverso una consapevolezza
si parlava prima del 2 che mi hanno
preceduto uomini di scienza e mettevano
in evidenza la sostenibilità che se
andiamo avanti in questa maniera il
futuro non ce lo garantisce nessuno
Allora noi partiamo Noi siamo innamorati
da un'idea che piccoli comuni
dell'entroterra italiano e non solo
italiano sono stati un po' ai margini
del vecchio sistema economico Siamo
stati un po' spettatori del sistema
economico Siamo stati ai margini sistema
economico questo stesso sistema canonio
che ad ossa mostra difetti il
cambiamento climatico primo ma anche
l'energia che che impazzita la carenza
di risorse in generale Allora noi che
siamo stati ai margini siamo innamorati
dell'idea che possiamo su questi
territori Sperimentare il nuovo modello
economico quello di dell'agenda 2030
dell'ONU quello che ci dice Papa
Francesco di immaginare un uomo un
sistema economico che Paradossalmente
deve essere più giusto deve essere più
Democratico più
partecipato e noi del nostro piccolo
abbiamo cercato di portare questi
principi in casi in casi concreti e
Paradossalmente Scommettendo su un
aspetto apparentemente un paradosso la
marginalità cioè la marginalità
l'elemento di negatività può essere
un'opportunità e aggiungo anche un
vantaggio competitivo
primo aspetto secondo aspetto noi
riteniamo abbiamo ritenuto in questi
anni che l'unico modo per vincere lo
spopolamento e creare un po' la
pirassiana e creare nuovi abitanti e
nuovi abitanti di si conquistano
attraverso la creazione di nuovo lavoro
quindi nuovo lavoro legato alle
peculiarità del nostro territorio
e quali sono gli elementi che hanno
ispirato questo questo modello queste
attività che abbiamo messo in campo il
primo e rileggere il territorio con
occhi diversi Noi siamo abituati a
guardarci con occhio molto negativo di
guardare il bicchiere mezzo vuoto e mai
mezzo pieno di guardare le cose che non
ci stanno Ecco noi abbiamo fatto lo
sforzo come comunità di guardare
Paradossalmente l'aspetto positivo e non
sovravalutare gli aspetti negativi che
anche un modo per arrendersi senza senza
senza combattere seconda cosa lo dicevo
anche prima proprio che siamo stati ai
margini non siamo stati contagiati dagli
effetti negativi del sistema economico
che ha caratterizzato la vita economica
sociale politica degli ultimi anni
abbiamo un grande patrimonio non
utilizzato del grande un grande risorsa
non intaccata e su questa grande risorsa
si può immaginare di implementare i
nuovi modelli di innovare noi siamo
innamorati dell'idea che delle aree
interne piccoli come italiani si
innovare oggi l'innovazione dell'aspetto
importante di qualunque genere sociale
economica tecnica amministrativa si
indoma i piccoli comuni perché
Paradossalmente nei piccoli comuni si
può anche sbagliare e correggere e
correggere il tiro si innova nei piccoli
comuni con l'ambizione poi di portare le
migliori esperienze le migliori
soluzioni in un contesto molto più ampio
Noi abbiamo anche un'idea per lo
sviluppo dei piccoli comuni e delle aree
interne del paese non servono soltanto a
chi ci abita egoista questa visione Noi
invece riteniamo che se parte lo
sviluppo delle aree interne che
rappresentano Ripeto il 60% del
territorio nazionale diamo un contributo
al paese siamo altruisti non siamo
egoisti vogliamo essere altruisti
vogliamo dare un contributo al paese
all'Italia intera Questo è il nostro
principio terzo elemento fondamentale la
condivisione con i cittadini con la
partecipazione anche un piccolo comune
di 320 abitanti il sindaco solo uno va
da nessuna parte Se non condivide le
proprie politiche le proprie azioni con
i propri cittadini ma la partecipazione
noi non abbiamo soltanto intesa come
condivisione come informazione abbiamo
chiesto ai nostri cittadini di essere
soggetti attivi e poi vi spiego in che
maniera
altro aspetto marginalità diventa
opportunità e l'elemento di forza io lo
definisco affettiva si è l'immigrazione
ha spogliato i piccoli cumulare interne
però fondamentalmente Il rovescio della
medaglia l'opportunità e costituita
dalle relazioni con le persone che sono
originali dei nostri genitori e l'altra
medaglia
dell'immigrazione e io l'ho chiamata
affettiva perché sono imprenditori che
operano con grande successo con i
talenti con esperienze con capacità
fuori dal territorio nostro Ma che se
opportunamente coinvolti possono dare un
contributo importante non soltanto in
termini economici in termini finanziari
ma in termini di imprenditoria in
termini di esperienza e di relazioni nel
proprio territorio di origine questo è
la sperimentazione che abbiamo messo in
campo
prima esperienza per dai principi ai
fatti alle realtà alle pratiche ai
progetti
lo spopolamento ci aveva lasciato il
nostro piccolo comune due strutture
abbandonate la scuola elementare e la
scuola materna Allora L'idea è quella di
trasformare in due strutture socio
sanitarie abbastanza banali sembra la
peculiarità l'innovazione e nel modello
di gestione abbiamo costituito una
società con i cittadini è diventata una
publi Company con 25-30 cittadini che
sono diventati soci investitori insieme
ad alcuni imprenditori affettivi per
tanti anni è stata l'unica RSA residente
sanitaria assistenziale della regione
Molise perché non ce n'erano le altre
siamo stati noi a ad anticipare i tempi
e quindi abbiamo realizzato questa
struttura che dopo 22 anni continua a
erogare i servizi a vantaggio alle
persone più deboli disabili e anziani e
a garantire e a garantire lavoro in
realtà difficile come la nostra questa
esperienza Al di là degli effetti e
degli obiettivi che avevamo raggiunto ha
donato forse il patrimonio più
importante di una piccola e di una
piccola comunità la fiducia Cioè nel
senso che anche un piccolo comune si
possono fare cose importanti
seconda iniziativa seconda marginalità
rappresentata dai terreni abbandonati ed
era esposti a rischio idrogeologico la
cultura ormai è molto marginale per le
ali interne questi terreni
Paradossalmente che sono intatti dal
punto di vista ambientale rappresenta
una grande opportunità lo diceva la
dottoressa precedentemente per fare
agricoltura biologica sono puliti per
definizione seconda aspetto non soltanto
che dovrebbero logica ma anche ritrovare
le cultivar vecchi cioè le mele antiche
e anche gli altri ortaggi attivi non
seguire la moda delle varietà
commerciali che si vendono in tutte e si
producono e si vedono in tutto il mondo
ma recuperare le coltiva informazioni
che hanno fatto la storia rurale dei
nostri dei nostri avi quindi terreni
abbandonati e trasformati in mediati
biologici e qui abbiamo una una una
delle foto che rappresentano un po' la
nostra iniziativa
tra l'ultima cosa che abbiamo messo in
campo e anche produrre Zafferano
biologico del nostro del nostro
territorio
altro aspetto altro progetto che abbiamo
portato avanti è quello di recuperare
altri terreni abbandonati per farci un
produzione di orzo
luppolo per farci gli ingredienti di una
birra agricola
Perché birra agricola perché visto che
c'è una forte diffusione di birrifici
artigianali però questi birrifici
artigianali gli ingredienti li
ricomprano sul mercato diciamo Nazionale
invece lo sforzo di innovazione
gestionale innovazione anche dal punto
di vista agricolo è quello di
implementare e produrre gli ingredienti
direttamente quindi la nostra birra
tutti gli ingredienti sono prodotti dal
nostro territorio
le varietà di birra che stiamo
producendo che stiamo commercializzato
altra esperienza importante Forse la più
impattante dal punto di vista visivo
marginalità rappresentata
dall'utilizzo mai marginale delle nostre
stalle devi coprire gli animali qui
all'interno di un'operazione di
rigenerazione urbana utilizzando gli
strumenti previsti dalla norma e
superando un tema importante molto
attuale della frammentazione Fondiaria
che caratterizza i terreni e gli
immobili dei piccoli Crudeli interne e
non solo abbiamo creato questa con il
coinvolgimento di alcuni privati e
soprattutto delle persone che ci avevano
di proprietà di questo ricoveri abbiamo
realizzato questo albergo diffuso che ad
oggi ospita 100 può arrivare a 100
persone a 32 case stalle barra stanze di
albergo e a due ristoranti dove un
centro benessere una sala convegno in
una ludoteca
Come erano patrimonio abbandonato dal
punto di vista della proprietà Ecco qui
come era fino a 10 anni fa il il
patrimonio rigenerato ed ecco come
attualmente sia la Piazza del Borgo Il
ristorante uno dei due ristoranti il
centro benessere con la piscina Ecco
altri ambienti in modo Ogni camera di
albergo è diversa perché ogni contesto
iniziale era era diverso
un'operazione di trasformazione urbana
pubblico e privato Il comune ha fatto il
comune a quindi ha recuperato risorse a
disposizione dello sviluppo locale e i
privati invece hanno fatto
l'investimento sulla parte diciamo
veramente alberghiera su questa cosa
piace fare un'altra delle osservazioni
un piccolo comune riteniamo che non deve
avere tanti obiettivi deve concentrare
l'attenzione sugli obiettivi che ritengo
più strategici Perché molte volte il
rischio è quello di concentrare la
propria attenzione su più fronti
dimenticando quale aspetto più
importante mi piace sempre una frase di
Seneca che dice che non esiste vento
favorevole per il marinaio che non sa
dove andare anche quindi anche un
piccolo comune deve indicare la rotta e
deve cercare di seguire di utilizzare
tutte le risorse tutti gli sforzi in
funzione di questo di questo obiettivo
altre immagini del
del Borgo recuperato
altra esperienza sempre all'interno di
una missione strategica e
l'apicoltura abbiamo
all'interno di un progetto di formazione
perché la formazione è fondamentale non
si fa nulla senza una formazione sia una
scuola quindi ancora più importante
abbiamo
formato 30 persone non solo del giudice
che sono diventati apicoltore
all'interno di un percorso di cielo di
formazione ogni apicoltore produce il
proprio miele questo miele viene poi
trasformato all'interno di un piccolo
laboratorio che chiamiamo di comunità
gestita da una cooperativa di comunità e
che produce e commercializza con un
marchio che sia proprio piano di
comunità Adesso alcune immagini tratte
dalla piano e anche il prodotto che
viene che viene commercializzato da
qualche tempo
per chiudere il cerchio abbiamo
innovazione sociale Abbiamo anche una
cooperativa di comunità noi come
comunità sono dei grandi suggestioni che
stanno avendo un grande successo di
piccoli crurali interne che hanno la
peculiarità di coniugare obiettivi
diciamo personali cioè di produrre
occupazione produrre reddito a chi ci
lavora con obiettivi di estiralità
diciamo ambientale e di contesto cioè la
comunità i propri le proprie opportunità
ai propri bisogni questa cooperativa di
comunità oltre a gestire una serie di
servizi a vantaggio del comune gestisce
l'unico alimentari del paese che vende
prodotti alimentari gestisce una
stazione bike gestisce Da qualche
settimana anche il doposcuola che
garantiamo ai nostri bambini di
un'assistenza e gestisce anche un
progetto di recupero e di integrazione
dei migranti perché noi riteniamo che se
in modo diligente in modo moderato
l'immigrazione dei piccoli comuni può
una grande opportunità purché
all'interno di un disegno molto più
ampio e molto più strategico
gli migranti che all'interno di un
percorso di integrazione lavorano nelle
nostre Le nostre aziende insieme
ai giovani del paese perché dicevo prima
nei piccoli comuni non è più sufficiente
trattenere gli abitanti ma bisogna avere
la capacità attrattiva e la capacità
attrattiva sia se si è capaci di creare
il lavoro adesso mi piace chiudere con
una frase e che poi una foto abbastanza
emblematica uno degli ultimi anziani del
paese che aveva il proprio la propria
stalla perché sono stati in questo
operazione lunga di vent'anni I primi i
principali alleati un paradosso uno
pensa che nei piccoli comuni gli anziani
e il paese sono hanno lo sguardo rivolto
al passato in modo nostalgico invece i
nostri anziani il paese e questa è una
strada molto bella Invece di guardare
con no Ero passato hanno guardato al
compositività al futuro della loro
piccola comunità e sono stati i
principali alleati degli amministratori
del sindaco in particolare e a me piace
sottolinearlo e mi piace evidenziare con
una frase di una proverbio Greco una
società cresce e diventa grande quando
gli anziani piantano alberi la cui ombra
sanno che non potranno sedersi Questo è
un principio di speranza e anche in
degenerazionale e che è molto bello e
seconda cosa e chiudo
Io
anche queste operazioni che sembrano
così importanti
non sono
risolutive delle problematiche dei
piccoli crude all'interno però danno un
segno che se uno ognuno facesse il
proprio contributo con un po' la
filosofia del colibrì della famosa fase
frase fiaba
africana può dare il contributo c'è
anche una piccola goccia può dare un
contributo a risolvere il problema
questo non soltanto dei piccoli comuni
ma nell'intero paese Grazie
[Applauso]